[Music]
okay hi it's uh producer ben
this is one question friday this is
where we take one question from a
listener and we answer it on air
today i'm answering it because sam and
sean took a long weekend they left a
little early on friday and
a few of you asked questions
to me because i was on the show a little
more than usual this week
so i figured i would answer one of those
questions so let's play it and before we
go into the question as always if you
want to leave a question for sam and
sean to answer usually sam and john
go to
mfmpod.com and click on the microphone
in the lower right hand corner and you
can leave a question and if we select
your question your voice will be on air
be on my first million uh okay let's get
to the question
hi this is jeremy my question is for
producer ben
what did you do to get your podcast
found by famous people like sam and mr
beast
and do you have any advice for how to
develop a good idea for a podcast
okay so to answer the first question
what did i do to get my podcast found by
sam mr beast so the first answer that i
have to give honestly is
nothing i'm extremely lucky that's how i
feel and uh but i yeah i don't know like
the first time i heard sam mention how
to take over the world on
my first million uh you may have heard
me use analogy before but i felt like i
was watching tv and then all of a sudden
the newscaster like looks out of the
screen and is like you i'm talking to
you it was very bizarre very weird um i
had no expectations no knowledge that he
was gonna mention it and it just totally
caught me by surprise because i was
already a fan of my first million
um so i don't have like a deliberate
strategy or anything like that for
getting famous people to find and
like my podcast i feel like all the
strategy is essentially just
the content um which leads into the
second question do i have any advice for
how to develop good ideas for podcasts
and yes i do because i get pitched a lot
of podcast ideas a lot of people come to
me and most of them are
good but bad uh what do i mean by that
good but bad the worst thing that your
idea can be as a podcast is fine and
that's my reaction to most people's
ideas for podcasts i go
yeah that sounds fine and there's a
problem with fine
and this is the problem i uh so before i
worked in media before i did podcasting
i did management consulting and i was on
this one project
where we worked for a security sales
company they
guys go to door to door and sell
security systems
and they had a problem which was they
had all these fraudulent sales and all
these fraudulent sales as we looked into
it would happen
at the same time of the year it happened
at the end of the summer
and so as we dug into it what we found
out was that the salesman for the
security system
were incentivized such a way where they
had these really steep
steps where it was like if you sell nine
security systems you will make
five thousand dollars but on your tenth
security system it jumps up to twenty
thousand dollars
which is totally crazy right so what you
would get is you have all these summer
salesmen who are just selling for the
summer and they have to hit
these certain steps they have to hit a
certain number of sales and if they do
they're gonna get this huge lump sum so
towards the end of the summer they're
really trying to hit
uh these numbers and they get panicked
and they start just selling accounts
like crazy even if that means
fudging the numbers a little bit selling
systems fraudulently stuff like that so
it's a big problem so we go tell them
hey this is a big problem uh you should
do a more
gradual incentive structure
and the executives at the security
system company told us you know we've
actually tried that and it didn't work
sales went way way down when we did that
not just the fraudulent bad sales at the
end of the summer yes we got rid of
those but overall sales went way way
down
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
and uh so we thought that was
interesting so
why do you think that is and what they
said was
panic
is an
exponentially greater motivator than
mere desire so
you might want something and you'll work
a little harder to get something
that you want but if you're panicked
then you'll work ten times harder okay
exponentially greater and um
and i think that's true and i think
that's true of podcasting of content as
well
too many people think oh well i'll just
produce something that's okay that's
good that's fine that's inoffensive i'm
gonna
try and capture as big of an audience as
i possibly can what you really need to
be optimizing for instead is
not panic obviously but obsession
it's better to have a smaller audience
with a very few people who are totally
obsessed with your podcast and so every
decision i made with my podcast which a
history podcast called how to take over
the world
was with that in mind so for example
when i first started telling my friends
and family i'm making this history
podcast called how to take over the
world uh everyone told me the same thing
which is
that name is like too aggressive you
need to chill a little bit uh can you
call it something like a little milder
how about you know life lessons from
history and um
i just thought
no i think i
really really want to make a podcast
called how to take over the world and i
think i would be obsessed with a podcast
called how to take over the world i was
just like how cool is that everyone
wants to know how to take over the world
or not everyone but i do i don't know
how to take over the world but sounds
incredibly interesting
similarly if you go listen to the
podcast
it's intro music
is uh is now iconic a lot of people love
it but
a lot of people when they first heard it
said oh that beat is like really
aggressive if you listen to it it's a
very aggressive intro song and so a lot
of people tried to talk me out of it
they said it's good but can you back off
a little bit can you make it like just a
little less bro and a little less out
there
and if i had done that
it would be more agreeable to more
people but there would not be
as many people who are obsessed people
are obsessed with that intro song people
love it and so to me that is
the key to good content
these really really strong emotions so
um
you need to get people obsessed uh you
need people to feel
um panicked right if it's if it's a
podcast about like a a social issue you
need people to feel terrified feel
horrified uh mortified that this thing
is happening that you're trying to to
illuminate and too many people go
well this is a good idea right like this
is interesting
and
that doesn't cut it and so i think the
fact that i made a podcast that honestly
does not appeal to some people and i i
think a lot of people don't realize that
but like some people are very turned off
by a podcast called how to take over the
world this aggressive intro music
and but that's okay because it's more
than made up for by the fact that a few
people are obsessed with it
and they
will then tell other people about it
they evangelize the podcast and that is
ultimately how
people like sam mr beast heard about it
was
through the grapevine
and so
yeah uh thanks for the question jeremy
that's my advice make stuff that people
are obsessed with okay uh next week one
question friday we'll be back to sam and
sean thank you for tuning in
[Music]
you